in this lesson we look at uh how we
explain
who
owns or what belongs to whom
these are some of the expressions that
come up in this lesson
it begins with the question es vocami
is it your friend
we sometimes hear esco
but escotrami is
simpler
we also have this
question in the little episode is
i
am sorry i left out the question mark
here
uh so is this your friend is this your
book no no the e at the end of a me
telling us that it's a girlfriend
and of course the answer is
and notice that the su here
because there's an e and we would have
two e's together one e drops out and it
becomes c apostrophe the the apostrophe
in french usually implies that an e has
been replaced with an apostrophe
semolive
uh this whole idea of possession semoli
you sometimes even hear semen
uh it's mine
it's my book or my
thing
so
listen to this lesson more than a few
times because this whole idea of
expressing
possession is quite important
and uh
i find that
in the beginning if i listen often to
simple lessons some of these expressions
tend to be kind of engraved in my mind
so there you have it for the possession
possess it